Daniel: Hello everyone.
Thanks for joining the second meeting
where we're going to be discussing
chapter one.
It's the active Textbook group and it's
May 12, 2022.
You can click on my screen and that will
show you the full screen.
We updated the live meeting page a bit
and it's just like all these other pages,
a work in progress, but hopefully this
will be a structure where we'll be able
to hear everyone's perspective and leave
the coda in a better place than we found
it.
So what we'll do in the live meetings,
which from here on out, or at least for
here for the next two and a half months
or so, are going to be driven by the
material in the chapters and in the
appendices.
We're going to go to the questions page
and we're going to look at the questions
that have been asked for that week for
that theme, and we're just going to start
with the most upvoted questions.
And then we're going to be taking notes
in the answers, in the discourse, and we'
'll go into a little bit more detail when
we flip to that page.
And then after addressing questions for
probably most of the time and discussing
that, we'll go pull back a little bit
more broadly like ideas for that week.
And then in the last minutes we can just
see if there's been any changes to the
project ideas and start to see what
people are excited about applying active
inference to.
And then we'll end at the top of the hour
and take a quick break.
And then there'll be a Tools
organizational unit meeting following for
those who want to just listen or
participate in tools.
So let's head over to Questions and I'm
going to hide the sidebar because we're
going to be mostly here in Questions.
Okay, so it's awesome.
And also Control and plus minus or
Control and scroll is like a good way to
resize how it looks.
So this is our first week with this
format and anyone's welcome to suggest a
variant or a different way to carry this
out.
But the co organizers of the textbook
group kind of thought we could do
something along these lines.
The questions we're going to be looking
at are in chapter one.
So that's the chapter we're discussing
today and we're going to start with the
ones that have the most upvotes in the
interesting and just spend a couple of
minutes on each of the questions.
And at any point there are the
affordances of just listening and also,
of course re watching this recording.
There's also the affordance in gather to
raise your hand if you'd like to share on
that question that we're going to have up.
.
And additionally by clicking on the
answers in discourse, that will pull up a
focused view on that question and
everybody can collaboratively edit the
answers and discourse.
And so it's better to add and be noisy
even if it's a bullet point list or an
incomplete sentence or there's
incoherence or it's contradictory.
Those are all fine.
It just adds information and perspectives
to the question.
So, yeah, we're going to go to each
question, open up the answers and
discourse, read the question, see what
has already been contributed in the
answers and discourse.
And then also if people want to share
other thoughts that they're having, that'
's awesome.
And then also if anybody wants to be
taking other notes, just things that are
coming to mind that they don't want to
share in a speaking way or just taking
some notes on what other people are
saying.
So let's just go into it.
And I'll be just keeping an eye for the
raised hand in gather for anybody who
wants to speak.
So starting with this first question,
maybe we can have addressed during
recording or something like that.
How do you understand the distinction
between the high road and the low road to
active inference?
What do you think is interesting or
useful about this distinction?
So does anybody want to just summarize
how they were thinking about the high and
the low road?
Or we can look at what others have
already written here.
What is the difference between the high
road and the low road?
Are there other roads?
Are there high and low roads to other
theories?
What is this metaphor with the roads?
So let's check out yes.
Ali and then Mallory.
Ali: Well, I believe it's just another
term for top down or bottom up approach
in a kind of way.
And well, the high road, I believe,
starts from the actualized mind itself
and tries to derive the underlying
mechanisms or underlying principles.
But the bottom up approach, or in other
words, low road, tries to start from the
elements, tries to start from the
unorganized elements, let's say, and
derive the higher mechanisms or higher
order mechanisms actualizing the mind
itself.
Daniel: Thank you.
Awesome.
Mallory.
Mallory: Yeah.
I was just going to maybe recapitulate, I
guess, what I wrote in the comments, and
I see now that I probably should have
written straight in the Answers in
Discourse section.
So sorry about that.
But I really appreciated this schematic
because I've read papers that I think
come at active inference from both of
these angles.
And in trying to understand.
I don't.
Know, the framework, I think it wasn't
super clear to me how all of these
different terms that are really nicely
outlined in this figure, Figure 1.2, are
related to one another.
So just to have it, I think, laid out
like this, it was really very helpful and
I think still being kind of new to the
concepts and such.
I liked the way they framed it in terms
of kind of the high road describing the
kind of what and why and the low road
being more about the how.
I thought that was really very useful.
So, yeah, I loved it and I saved it and
will probably reference it quite often.
Daniel: Yeah, agreed.
It's really useful.
And it touches on Aristotle's multiple
whys, where some of the whys are more
like hows or they're sort of proximate
mechanisms or more ultimate mechanisms.
And we can look at Figure 1.2.
So active inference is in the middle and
the high road.
I guess this is the starting train stop
here with a free energy principle, which
some later questions also might invoke.
And then it kind of goes down to active
inference, whereas starting with Bayes
theorem also gets us to sentient behavior,
, sentient being like sensing and feeling
and acting not as much on the qualia and
experiential side.
So what else do we have in the answers?
So high road, what and why that is
starting with sort of the organismal
imperative, or like Ali, I think, said,
there the actualized mind.
And then what are the underlying
principles that make adaptive behavioral
systems working down the castle in the
sky is the adaptive behavior and
intelligent cognitive behavior, what is
under it?
And then the low road doesn't begin with
that imperative.
It starts with the elements, like the low
road, starting with Bayes.
None of these necessarily have to be, or
at least maybe until you get to Bayesian
brain.
These don't have to be adaptive.
A generative model doesn't have to be
resisting entropy.
So it's sort of like here's where we see
a lot of the elements in the machinery
and then on the top is more of the self
organization resistance to dissipation
autopoiesis.
How are you going to get there?
You have to be minimizing your surprise.
What does that actually entail?
And then active inference is like this
intermediate stop.
And again, maybe there's other roads or
there's other paths.
Any other thoughts on high road and low
road?
Or we'll continue to the next question.
This is just being introduced in chapter
one because the following chapters two
and three, which we're going to get to
after the appendix A and B are going to
detail the low road and the high road.
So this is kind of like a map for some of
the next steps that we're going to be
engaging in.
Okay, next question.
The concept of organisms minimizing
surprise is introduced on page six.
How are prior assumptions or beliefs
established when the organism is in new
or novel environments?
So anyone can raise their hand or take a
note here Mallory or Ali with raised
hands.
One helpful approach might be to think
about like the question is asking about
new and novel environments.
So are we dealing with categorical
novelty or with quantitative novelty?
Like, I was measuring the temperature and
then I'm in a new environment where the
temperature is different.
That's one type of novelty.
But there might also be like this novelty
at an even higher level with like I was
looking at previously, I was looking at
temperature, and now I'm in a place where
I'm having priors about smell.
So that's like a sort of intermodal or
like a different type of thing that's
being tracked.
So that's a categorical novelty as
opposed to just updating the temperature
parameter in a different temperature room,
, whether the person who asked it is here
or not.
Oh, yes.
Okay.
Ali and Mike, go for it.
Ali: Yeah.
Well, again, if we're talking about the
human mind from the priors, we can infer
that well, it's something that's kind of
innate in human minds, something wired,
and I mean, perhaps genetically or in any
other biologically hardwired way, but
well, again, yes, the definition of a
novel situation varies according to what
we're exactly referring to.
And if a novel situation is something
that the organism hasn't ever presented
with, well, in that case, these priors or
these innate tendencies won't help it
very much.
So in that case, it should probably go
along the way of constructing posteriors,
more actively, I believe, than in any
regular situation.
Daniel: Thank you, Ali.
Jessica;
and then Mike;
and then Steve.
Jessica: Hi.
I think maybe like, in this situation,
even though the agent might be
encountering something that hasn't
experienced before, they might use
something as proxy that they already know
and sort of like, project those
understanding into the new situation.
And then it's through action, et cetera.
Then they're going to be updating like,
okay, how true is it or isn't to what
they understand; but they might be making
some kind of projection based on what
they already know and things that look
similar to that new experience.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you.
Mike and Steven.
Mike: Yeah, I was just going to comment.
In the case where the organism is brand
new and has no experience, I think Ali's
comments covered this a bit, that it will
have to be updating its priors fairly
rapidly and presumably starting with sort
of a wider distribution.
Daniel: Great.
Steven?
Steven: Yes.
Along the lines of what Jessica was
saying.
There has been some work in systematizing
that as case based reasoning.
Not necessarily in a Bayesian framework
here, but as a derivative of expert
systems, where when you get a new
scenario, you try to match that against
previous scenarios that you've already
seen and adapt it however necessary to
meet the new observations.
So that might be a place to look for
inspiration.
Daniel: Thanks.
Yeah.
And in the ontology work, and in a lot of
these questions, there's often like a
narrow answer and then a broader answer.
Like the narrow answer would be well,
again, if all your Bayesian model is
doing is looking at the thermometer
reading and then doing a calm and filter
and inferring the temperature in the room,
, well, then the answer of what happens
when you put it underwater or what
happens when you ask it to predict scent.
.
It's kind of like a trivial answer, which
is it's just not a parameter.
In that script, nothing happens.
And then that's like the narrower answer,
which is often very deflationary or like,
very trivial answers.
And then there's also a broader question,
like in the ecological context or in the
organismal context, in the expert applied
context, what happens when there are
these different qualitative and
quantitative types of novelty?
And so sometimes it's like, there we are
in the middle again with the deflationary
or the narrow being too obvious and too
simple to be brought into action.
And then the bigger question, like how do
experts in medicine or some other field,
how do they handle different types of
novelty?
That's its own research question and
agenda.
Awesome.
Any other thoughts on this question about
priors?
And it's also very important note that
surprise is always relative to
expectations which are priors in the
Bayesian context, and those are granted
by the Generative model.
So surprise is not just free floating, it'
's in relationship to the outcomes as
expected by an organism, for example,
jessica, your hands raised, otherwise we'
'll go to the next question.
Awesome.
This question, I think, is pretty similar
to the previous one.
So if anybody wants to give a thought
otherwise, no worries.
Are the high road and low road the only
roads to active inference?
Or my active be like Rome, which I guess
we can unpack a little bit, many all
roads leading to it's.
J-F.
J-F: Yes, it's more of a general question.
.
For example, if what you're trying to
understand is race cars, right?
And you develop a mathematical framework
given a number of measurements, like the
weight of the car, the length of the car,
the torque of the engine, the adhesion of
the tires, the friction, and whatnot, you'
're able to predict how well the race car
is going to perform in different
conditions.
And whatnot does that mean that you're an
expert in race cars?
Does that explain the race car?
Could you engineer a race car based on
this knowledge?
So, talking about multiple different
roads, one road through the free energy
principle, I think is an analytical road
that looks at the outcomes of the
machinery of the living beings that try
to maintain homeostasis.
But how much does it say about the
implementation of those organisms?
Um, it says many things, but does it say
everything that we deem might deem
interesting?
So what are the limitations of this
framework, the active inference framework
defined by.
Daniel: The free energy principle?
J-F: What are its limitations on top of
what it given its capabilities, which are
which are, I think, enormous.
But there are limitations.
And and if there are limitations, that
means there are there must be other roads
that can be taken to circumvent these
limitations.
Daniel: Thank you.
Great comment, Ali.
Ali: Well, duluzan Gatavi in 1000
Plateaus has laid out the concept of
Rhizome.
I don't know if you're familiar with the
concept of Rhizome as opposed to an
arborescent structure.
Well, basically, the concept of Rhizome
expounds a knowledge structure in which
every concept can potentially be
connected to every other concept without
having to go through a principal trunk of
a knowledge tree, let's say, but in an
arborescent structure and not arborescent
knowledge structure, everything branches
up from a principal trunk, from a
principal, let's say, base.
And I believe that in active inference, a
Rhizomatic approach can also be explored
not only by approaching to different
concepts via the high road or the low
road main or principal trunk.
It can potentially be approached from
seemingly unrelated concepts too.
Daniel: Awesome to maybe even approach a
limitation or a seemingly unrelated
concept.
Both the high and the low road in this
textbook are formal, and they're both
grounded in, like, mathematical symbols.
So are there qualitative or non
mathematical roads?
Maybe some of the early roads are
mathematical, but is it possible that a
future road or path or tunnel or choose
your travel metaphor might not be that
case?
And then thanks for sharing.
That the resource there, because this is
another interesting angle which various
people have traced this evolution of
visual metaphor where it's like, things
are ladder like and scalar, and then
there's more of a bifurcating tree, and
then that becomes critiqued or
complexified into more of a network, like
with integration among species, for
example.
So there's sort of this movement from
linear through a tree, like a directed
acyclic graph towards something that's
more networked.
So that's a lot of interesting ideas.
Anything else that people want to add or
we'll continue on.
Okay, on page ten, they write, creatures
engaging in active inference actively
seek out salient sensory observations
that resolve their uncertainty.
So what is the relationship between
salience and the kind of observation that
reduces uncertainty?
Why is the relationship between salience
observation and uncertainty this way?
How does active inference frame this
relationship similarly or different from
which other specific frameworks?
So someone wrote, I like this question a
lot, eager to get a better understanding
of what constitutes salience.
Is salience referencing information that
is self evidence or information that is
precise and surprising or dot dot, dot?
Yes.
I think attention and salience is
addressed more in papers on active
inference than at least just from a
preliminary pass of the book.
So attention and metacognitive mechanisms
are not going to be a core feature in the
book.
However, there's again been a lot of
interesting work on the neurobiology and
the computational aspects of salience and
attention.
We can click on the word and see a
definition, but this is not like the
final definition.
This is just what some have gotten to.
Salience is the extent to which a queue
or an observation commands the attention
of an agent, given their regime of
attention.
So potentially a little bit tautological,
like a salient observation is something
that is grabbing attention.
A salient cue is something that commands
attention.
Steven.
Steven: Yes, I would say that, especially
if we're defining it in that way, that
there are two elements to salience, and
one is what was pointed out in the
question, I guess, that you are reducing
uncertainty.
But there is also the question of what
uncertainty is worth reducing, and that
gets into utility and where it makes
sense to explore.
I don't know if we want to choose to
change the definition of salience to just
be the second of those or leave it as
having both of those elements.
Daniel: Thanks! Mallory?
Mallory: I think something I don't
necessarily understand, which I would
appreciate maybe somebody speaking to a
little bit, is this is related actually
to a question I put in earlier about the
distinction between perception and
learning, but something that grabs
attention.
Are we distinguishing?
So that would say that something is I
like the point that was just made.
Something is salient if it reduces
uncertainty, if we're also attending to
things in order to actively construct a
niche that is consistent with our model
of the world, would we not consider that
something like that object as attracting
attention as opposed to our how do we
distinguish, I guess, between active
sampling and attending?
And how is that related to salient?
So something salient either if it is
surprising or if it is serving the
purpose of kind of like fulfilling a
prediction.
I'm not sure I understand that kind of
distinction.
Daniel: I'm not sure that makes sense,
but awesome question.
And this is one reason why looking at the
formalisms and how they're framed will
help us, because in the purely English
linguistic realm, we could imagine
sentences of any type.
So in the active inference formalisms,
what are being tagged with salience?
Which variables are said to reflect
salience?
And then are they or in what ways are
they related to this concept of surprise,
which we're going to get to in a question
soon, versus utility?
And this is also speaking to the way that
expectations and preferences in active
inference are framed differently than in
certain other frameworks.
Joe: Can I jump in and just ask another
question about this question rather than
an answer, which is, wouldn't some data
be salient even if it's sensible?
Like we might have two levels of salience.
.
So I just put this quote in about the
notion of a, umvelt being a more or less
broad series of elements called carriers
of significance or marks, which are the
only things that interest the animal.
Now, interest the animal is one thing,
but even just perceiving those marks as
existing, I mean, active inference does
have room for that in terms of each agent
having some sensory data.
So you could say, well, since I can't see
infrared light, it's not salient to me
when I'm out in a field of flowers, but a
bee can see that, I think.
It can see infrared or ultraviolet.
I can't remember which one.
So it may be a salient concept for me as
a thinking agent, but it's not one that's
salient for me when I'm navigating a
field of flowers.
Daniel: Basically.
Nice thanks for bringing in, umvelt, and
a lot of ecological psychology terms do
make their way to active.
And so then you brought up like levels of
perception and salience.
For example, there's things that are
outside of the wavelength that can be
perceived.
So photons are not going to be perceived
at that wavelength, but then there might
be within the visible range novel
arrangements like there's something
moving there or there might be something
that is static yet commands attention,
like the Mona Lisa.
So what is happening when somebody's
regime of attention is fixated on static
artifact versus something where they're
being fixated on something that's rapidly
changing, like a movie mallory in the
chat you wrote, can folks recommend
papers?
So definitely people can recommend papers
anywhere they see fit.
And one place to check out is in the
bottom of our coda.
In the live streams, under the live
stream tab, you'll find like 45 papers
that we've relatively extensively
discussed.
And so these are not like the only or the
canonical papers or anything, but there's
a lot of important ones in there.
So especially if you're interested in
looking at papers where people in the lab
might have familiarity or there's some
things to listen to or watch about it,
then these are some good places to start.
.
All right, awesome.
Next question.
All right, this is a contextualization
question.
This is not a metadata contextualizing
sentence.
On page nine and ten they talk about
differences from alternative frameworks.
For example, in contrast with other
frameworks, policy selection in active
inference automatically balances
exploration and exploitation.
And later, active inference extends the
inferential approach to domains of
cognition that are rarely considered.
What are five to seven examples, names in
a sentence of other theories and
frameworks that active inference improves
upon or updates.
Anyone can raise their hand.
This is an excellent homework
collaborative stigma gqueston because
even if each person only thought of one
novel answer here with a link and a name
or somebody improved what somebody else
had already brought very quickly as a
textbook group, we could have quite a
coherent and comprehensive list.
The idea of balancing exploration and
exploitation, so called, is going to be a
key theme.
And the way that active inference does
handle this trade off, not through the
use of an exploratory mode or
exploitative mode or some parameter that
is like governing the handoff.
There like some sort of x times
exploration plus one minus x of
exploitation.
That is like one approach that's commonly
used, but it would be a question of which
citations use that type of an approach
and it's going to come to the epistemic
and pragmatic value.
Whereas when there's little epistemic
value to be gleaned, little informational
uncertainty to resolve, then pragmatic
value can be pursued, which is reducing
the surprise about outcomes in
relationship to preferences.
And then on the other hand, when there's
a lot of uncertainty, exploratory
behavior might be engaged in because
there isn't enough certainty around how
to pursue those pragmatic aims.
And these are going to come into play
with the Tmaz mouse model that's going to
be later in the book.
But this is a great question.
So anyone want to just give an example of
some other theory or framework or some
other approach to thinking about
exploration exploitation?
One starting reading, if anyone is
interested, there is a 2015 paper that is
looking at exploration and exploitation
trade offs in different domains.
Ali.
Ali: Well, I don't know if it necessarily
improves upon, but certainly an
alternative approach to this theory can
be Steven Grossberg's art theory, the
adaptive resonance theory that we talked
about previous session.
In that theory, the problem of learning
and cognition is attacked from the
viewpoint of solving the stability
plasticity dilemma.
And in this context, in the context of
art or adaptive resonance theory, well or
let's say the difference between the
active imprint one of the main
differences between the active imperence
or any predictive coding schemes from
adaptive resonance theory is that in
Bayesian models generally, the fully
suppressive matching circuits I mean, the
the circuits that can propagate the
information.
It cannot solve the stability plasticity
dilemma as opposed to the art or adaptive
Bresnan's theory.
Daniel: So plasticity being more
exploratory and openness to updates and
stability being more like parametric lock
in more exploitative within a certain
realm.
Ali: Yeah, the plasticity refers to a
system that doesn't have catastrophic
forgetfulness.
Daniel: Awesome cool.
So we can just have this question up and
check back and people can add things.
We'll just look at a few more questions.
So on page eight they write the high road
perspective is useful to understand the
normative nature of active inference,
what the living organisms must do to face
their fundamental existential challenges.
.
Minimize free energy.
And why?
The what and the why in the high road why
to vicariously minimize the surprise of
their sensory observations?
What does it mean to minimize surprise
vicariously?
So someone has written interesting choice
of words.
Here are two possible answers.
Also, the authors or the readers
participants may have something else in
mind.
Vicarious might refer to the point on
page six that agents cannot tractably
minimize surprise as the authors
technically defined it in chapter two
coming up.
So instead they're going to minimize an
approximation to surprise, which is
variational free energy.
However, I'm not sure if they're
referring to the two types of surprise
that are going to be approached in
chapter two, which is the marginal
surprise like informational surprise and
then the Bayesian surprise or both.
So one option is surprise as defined one
way or the other, or both cannot be
directly calculated or it's not tractable
to pursue.
And so the vicarious could mean like
indirect or via a proxy.
And in that case something like
variational free energy is being
vicariously minimized and then that is
going to be used to get at the surprise
minimization and the second option the
person has written vicarious might refer
to the point that agents minimize free
energy not only in response to real
sensory observations, but in anticipation
of them.
Those anticipations could come from
internal simulations, by subroutines or
other modules, or memory from recall of
past observed events.
Page 32, which is probably in chapter two.
.
The author seemed to be referring to
engaging models vicariously in a
counterfactual sense, dealing with
imagined surprise at presumed
observations.
So these are really important comments.
We have the indirect minimization of
surprise using a proxy.
So some type of heuristic to minimizing
surprise now.
And so that is vicarious but contemporary.
.
And then the second sense is whether we'
're using a proxy or not is referring to
observations that haven't occurred so
anticipated or expected observations.
Hopefully we'll come back to in chapter
two.
But these are important questions and it'
's going to speak to like variational
free energy and expected free energy and
free energy of the expected future, a few
other constructs.
Steven and yeah, I put that last comment
in.
Steven: I was just thinking that should
probably go under number two there.
I guess that would be evidence of that
second interpretation.
Daniel: Thank you.
So we'll maybe return to this in chapter
two.
Okay, let's just see if we can look up
just a few of these questions.
It's awesome, like how many there are and
of course anyone can always read and
contribute asynchronously.
All right, the subtitle of the book is
the free energy principle in Mind, Brain
and Behavior.
What is the relevant distinction between
mind and brain in the context of the free
energy principle?
Someone has written really appreciate how
the researchers have started proposing
biological implementations of Active in
the brain.
But it's not clear to me how this maps
onto related psychological concepts like
colloquial, surprise predictions,
salience, arousal.
Yeah, awesome.
And there's been some recent work and
some work that we're going to be looking
at in Live Stream 46 on active inference
and folk psychology about connecting some
of the formalisms to folk psychological
concepts.
So that's one place we'll be looking at
that.
But how does or does active approach this
mind brain question?
Whether the Cartesian dualist question,
hard problem of consciousness,
intentional stance of dennett.
Why is the subtitle of the book that way,
Jessica?
And then anyone else with the raised
hand?
Jessica: Yes.
I mean, I don't know the answer, but if I
make a guess, I think maybe the mind will
be more the cognition and the brain
looking at the physiology and then
looking at behaviors.
That would be my guess.
Daniel: Yeah.
Awesome.
Bacterium does not have a brain, but does
it have a mind also?
Great questions.
We'll just continue just these questions
with fewer upvotes because there's a
bunch just so we can get them in.
So generative model is used in the
singular or is used in the singular as in
the generative model or in the.
Plural, as in hierarchical generative
models.
Is a generative model composed of
generative models?
I e.
Is it structurally fractal?
Someone has written personally, I think
the answer is yes.
Or it's possible to answer yes via
referencing a paper that talks about
blankets of blankets, Markov Blankets
life.
This paper definitely does think about
the nesting of multi scale complex
systems in terms of nested generative
models that then are constituting yes,
that are then constituting generative
models at a higher level.
So, like, there's people with their
generative model and then the team has a
generative model of a different type.
J-F: JF yes, but even an individual
myself yourself, can be characterized as
having a generative model composed of
other general models dealing with less
abstract umvelt, for example.
So I think yes, I think almost trivially
in the sense of a collective, but in the
sense of an individual, does an
individual also can be said to possess a
generative model that is itself composed
of sub generative models?
Daniel: Awesome point.
And we've in several live streams and
settings discussed.
Like, there's one sense where nesting is
used to refer to systems that are
potentially even physically nested.
And then we also see the nesting
architecture.
For example, here it's live stream number
25 when we discussed it.
But this is a nesting of attentional and
cognitive models.
So this is even of a so called individual.
.
So what is it about model nesting when
sometimes it can refer to physical
enclosure and other times it is something
that enables counterfactual reasoning,
attention and metacognition.
So what is the nesting?
And if someone is just seeing this kind
of a notation or this kind of a graph for
the first time, we're going to totally go
into it.
But it's going to be one of the core
formalisms.
And also this paper is going to deal with
nested models and other papers do.
The textbook is going to spend almost all
the time on just one level.
So just sort of the kernel or the essence
or the archetype or the essential motif
of this partially observable Markov
decision process.
And the textbook is going to focus on
juxtaposing the discrete time partially
observable Markov decision process with a
continuous time.
But it will deal less with hierarchical
nesting.
But it does bring it up, but it's not
going to be focused on, okay, what is the
information content of a prediction?
I'm just going to read these ones just so
that those who are listening can see the
kinds of questions that they could be
adding or addressing.
This question has to do with the
relationship between active inference and
pleasant surprises, potentially even love
languages receiving money on the pavement.
.
Page five is speaking to the author's
rhetoric around theory proliferation and
integration where basically they are
saying well, we could have a dedicated
explanation for every neurotransmitter,
for every synaptic junction, every unique
behavior, every cognitive phenomena or we
could somehow utilize first principles,
whatever those are, to result in theory
integration.
And that gets mapped onto the scruffies
and the needs.
Is it really helpful to redefine terms
such as probability and surprise to
sometimes mean utility and divergence
from utility if that's what the authors
are doing?
There appears to be an unhealthy
ambiguity in how they use these terms.
This is where the formalisms are going to
really come into play.
And also the live stream on Free Energy A
User's Guide 37 deals with this dual
interpretation of expectations and
preferences.
And this is like one of the most
essential differences between active
inference and reward learning or
reinforcement learning frameworks is a
dual deployment of the same variable in
formalisms to represent preferred states
as well as expected states like
homeostatic range is expected and
preferred.
It's where one wants to be found and it's
where one expects to be found.
And so one can realize those preferences
by reducing their surprise about the
observations rather than saying, well,
homeostatic states are valuable and we're
going to pursue maximum value.
How might an acceptable state space
relate to the idea of a comfort zone?
It seems the acceptable state space for
an organism is necessary for it to
persist, whereas a comfort zone seems to
be a less necessary state repertoire
which if exceeded, may only indicate to
an organism that it's at risk of leaving
the acceptable state space.
Interesting.
And then the last written question here,
looking ahead into part two.
Have people been looking into the
computational complexity of the active
inference model and how far are we in
terms of making this computable and the
reference 2019 paper computational
Resource Demands of the Predictive
Bayesian Brain?
Excellent and important question to
understand, like the analytical
computational complexity, like the Big O
notation, does nesting a model make it
two or is it log the number of levels or
is it number of levels to the sum
exponent?
And then also in practice, like using
active block for instance, or Pi MDP,
what is the actual runtime of different
algorithms?
So this is awesome with the questions
that everyone's added to one.
We're going to keep on returning to
chapter one, just like we're going to
keep on returning to the ideas, but
people can fold it and continue to add to
two and to the appendices which we're
going to go to next week.
So just as a reminder, next week we're
going to be approaching appendix A and B,
which are mathematical.
And so just a few thoughts on that before
we return back to the ideas on the book.
In appendix A, you can see that all the
equations have already been added.
So if anyone wants to reference, what
does equation A point 44 mean?
And obviously like there's 60 equations
and you could get your PH.
D.
Learning about some sub function of just
one.
So we're just trying to familiarize and
get a first coat of paint.
So for those with different mathematical
backgrounds.
If somebody can derive the proof, amazing.
.
Let's take some notes on it.
And if somebody is just going to be
asking beginner questions that's also
very important.
So that will be in next week's questions
and discussions.
But let's just look at what ideas people
wrote and then see if there's any ideas
percolating.
So having addressed some specific
uncertainties I get with the questions we
can think about what are some impressions
that people were having and what was
exciting ideas.
So if Ben or Mike want to speak to this
or if anybody else wants to share
something JF and then anyone else JF and
then Ben or is your hand raised?
J-F: No, my hand was not raised.
Daniel: Okay.
Sorry, Ben.
Go for it.
Ben: Yeah, thanks.
Can you hear me?
Daniel: Yes.
Ben: Cool.
Daniel: Yeah.
Ben: Maybe I should have posed this as a
question.
Actually I just thought it was
interesting, this connection between
perception and learning as essentially
the same process unfolding over different
timescales.
Because on the one hand, this makes sense
to me because one example of learning
might be you can imagine an agent moving
to a new city with which they're
completely unfamiliar and the agent could
sit at a fixed point in the city or walk
around the city and just perceive the
city and they would learn over a longer
time scale.
They would observe certain regularities
or certain occurrences and clearly that's
one form of learning.
But then there's maybe another example
where my mathematical background is
fairly weak.
And so if I were to try and learn the
kind of fundamentals of the equations
that we were just looking at no matter
how for how long I kind of perceive those
equations I'm not going to learn them.
I have no access to kind, there's no
information gained there.
It seems like to learn certain things we
need to scaffold perception in certain
ways.
And I suppose my question would be when
somebody teaches us something that we don'
't understand, is that merely a kind of
scaffolded perception or is that kind of
learning underwritten by distinct
cognitive processing completely separate
from perception?
Daniel: Great question, thanks for
unpacking that.
And to give one thought, let's imagine a
ball moving across the visual fields.
It seems like a canonical example of
perception.
We're perceiving the ball but it could
also be understood as parameter updating
or parameter learning of the location of
the ball.
And then that's one approach.
But then also you pointed towards this
deeper sense of learning referring to the
underlying structures like in the ball
movement examples.
It seems like learning and perception are
the same but then learning might also
refer to something deeper like the
tendencies of how balls move.
Or one could, as probably many of us have,
, look at these symbols and perceive them
visually.
But because we wouldn't have learnt the
underlying generative model that gives
rise to these pixels, we could
continually be surprised.
So what is happening when there's
perception and learning seemingly
happening hand in hand.
And then other times where somebody's
speaking a language you don't understand,
you certainly hear it.
You may even be paying attention to it,
yet the next phoneme may still
continually surprise you.
So it's a really important question.
Then Mike wrote yes, please.
Go for it, Mike.
Mike: Yeah, so I think these are
straightforward but foundational concepts
that the dependence of sensory input on
action and vice versa creates a framework
where we can have feedback and then the
mathematical constructs let us think
about how we model that and simulate it.
Daniel: Thanks for this.
Also, a central point in active inference,
, there isn't a perception and inference
module that passes the perceptions to the
learning module, and the learning module
passes it to the decision making module
and the decision making module to the
action model.
The inference is conditioned upon policy
selection and action, and that is going
to approach this nexus of perception,
cognition and action in an integrated way
that not that may differ from other
frameworks, which was also to the point
of that previous question.
So this was an awesome session.
Everyone really appreciated it.
I'll upload the video recording following
the meeting next week.
At the same time, we'll be looking at
questions and ideas from appendix A and B.
.
So just approach those however you'd like
and annotate the coda.
And also, if anybody wants to specify
another time when they just want to
discuss or cowork that can be added, or
in the active lab discord, people can
join and we can have a voice like a study
hour or just a time to talk about stuff
or write down the questions we have.
So awesome work, everybody.
Thanks a lot.